back in those days back in the days the
wright brothers um
trying to figure out power control man
flight was all the rage it was like the
dot-com of the day so it's not like the
wright brothers are the only people
doing it
lots of people were doing it um and the
the lead contender was a guy named
samuel pierpon langley
langley was well known he uh
he was well respected
he was funded his efforts were funded by
the war department
the precursor of the dod so he was
very very well funded we had cash he
hired
literally the best engineers the best
mechanics the best mathematicians
that money could buy he had the dream
team and the new york times followed him
around everywhere and everyone was
rooting for langley
um the problem was langley was envious
of people like edison uh and
and and those like him and langley
wanted to be rich and famous
he was he was very selfishly motivated
and he saw
or at least his selfish motivation was
was number one
and you know figuring this thing out was
number two and he saw this figuring this
thing out
as the mechanism to help him become rich
and famous
then way off in dayton ohio uh
uh are the orville and wilbur wright who
own a bicycle shop
uh they have no money they don't have a
dream by the way
what's that that's nice to live there by
the way dayton ohio
oh okay um so they got this bicycle shop
they don't have a dream team they have
whoever works in their shop
uh they have no funding and
nobody knows who they are that nobody
even knows that they exist
the difference was they had a vision and
they were compelled that they
they realized that if they could figure
out this flying thing
it would have a profound and positive
impact on the world it would change the
world
and it's what motivated them to come
back day after day after day failure
after failure after failure they weren't
making money
and lo and behold when they figured it
out no one was even there like there was
no new york times there
uh you know they recorded it themselves
um and further proof that langley was
motivated by the wrong thing
which was he could have said amazing i'm
going to improve upon your tech
he didn't as soon as the wright brothers
were celebrated as figuring it out
langley quit you didn't have to
right but he did um so
so uh you know in in it's not money and
and dream team it's teamwork it's vision
and teamwork and shared cause
that that that makes for a
a great organization it goes back to the
very beginning of what we're we're
talking about
you know manipulation versus inspiration
which is if the people come together
inspired by
common cause and are willing to struggle
and suffer together it's more likely
they're going to solve a problem and
innovate
whereas if they come together and they
say what's in it for me and you know
will i get will i get i'm only doing
this if i get a huge bonus if i figure
this out
you know then what you end up happening
is you you don't have
amazing teamwork because people hoard
information because they think that
makes them more valuable
etc etc etc so it's it's really it's
great teams that innovate
it's not necessarily great individuals